okay James so we're you drivers from
Texas you're Houston right yeah he's
from Houston and would probably music
and acting I'm a singer and song right
so I tried doing that didn't work out
too well and then I tried acting so I
got two all year you got a great look I
did before I was homeless so I've seen
you in the street here like patched out
face down on the sidewalk it's up to all
the tear issue that works enough drugs
stand out at all I guess
yeah I use meth where you do sometimes
and then I drink to to come off the mat
but I mean usually I'm up for a few days
doing meth that I'm gonna pass out for a
day or two on the sidewalk and what age
did you start with the drinking and I
actually had a pretty good life up until
about my mid-20s
I mean I used a little bit when I was a
teenager you know I drink at parties
with friends and I did a few things here
and there you know took some acid a
little bit did a little bit of cocaine
when I was a teenager and I quit using
drugs completely and when I turned 18
and I was sober for years until my
twenties and my 20s I start drinking
when I became illegal to drink I started
drinking again and then after drinking
for a few years I began using again
which was something different it was
crystal meth so when I was about 25 26
years old 24 25 26 right around there I
started drinking
and using crystal and so I've been using
crystal for about ten years which I'm
trying to quit because 10 years on
crystal I mean it really [ __ ] you up
really bad like so while I'm you know
before it [ __ ] me up too bad I want to
[ __ ] quit using hold it 36 right so
it hasn't you said you'll see some
people out here that are 48 and they're
like yeah but that's what they say you
know ten years on crystal you quit it
you know like and that's all the rumors
I hear ten years on crystal man ten
years ten years you can't do it anymore
you can't do anymore it's gonna [ __ ] you
up to guys and [ __ ] you up to god so I'm
trying to quit
I've been trying to quit for a while now
um not so much alcohol is not really the
issue I don't think I don't think it's
the issue I think maybe I just I use
alcohol currently because I get high on
crystal too I smoke too much of it and
then I can't sleep or I can't get off of
it or you know so I drink to come down
off of it but yeah I mean drinking has
never been a problem I don't think I
mean I don't have a I have a problem
[Laughter]
what do you tell me about your childhood
was it like was there anything that
you're trying to like now think about
from your childhood or do you think it's
just you're more addicted then um my
family was really abusive to me
like all of my family yeah my brothers
my sisters my mom my dad they were all
abuse if my father was physically
abusive emotionally abusive to everyone
in the family he used to beat up on my
mom [ __ ] like that Pete up on us how
much to school one day and in fourth
grade and I had these like slashes on my
back of my thighs and on my back I can't
remember what my dad did it with it was
either a wire hanger or an extension
cord or
or or his belt that had like these
buffalo nickels on it I can't really
remember what he did it with but I
remember the incident and I remember my
father chasing me with something around
the house threatening me backed me into
a corner behind my behind my bedroom
door and just started and I turned my
head into the corner and just he just
went crazy on my back in my legs so my
sister decided it would be a good idea
to tell the counselor and then I had to
go in and I was in fourth grade I was
like 9 or 10 years old I think 10 years
old I had to go show the counselor and I
was like god damn it you know so my
sister ruined told the counselor and the
counselor called me in and said pull
your pants down take your clothes off
you know what your dad dude I was like
well he hit me yeah but so yeah I never
you see your your family as well yeah my
my family was abusive towards me as well
because I had some trust money I was
getting when I turned 18 so they were
all jealous of it when I turned 18 I got
some money from an accident I was in
when I was a child and
and so my whole family was very abusive
towards me as soon as I got that money
do you still have the money somewhere or
is it no now I spent it yeah burn
through it it wasn't really a lot of
money it's not like it was millions or
something like that in there but um it
was enough to get me started when I was
18 you know I went to college tab it
here and there
I when I came to California I went back
to college here in California to college
here I went I got uh I had like three
jobs I was waiting tables at bartending
and catering and I was going to LA CC
and and I was in a situation with a
roommate that didn't work out too well I
ended up homeless because I didn't have
any paperwork at the resident I was
staying at you know and he became
jealous of something for whatever reason
and I ended up being homeless
so yeah
so I mean is using the crystal meth is
keeping you from like getting your [ __ ]
together it yeah I mean it's possible
let me at me I've been on crystal for a
while now so I mean it's possible that
that's definitely part of it yeah we're
going to see what we got to see happen
for next five years for me that looks
quite using crystal you know I I using
that's bad yeah you see the future that
I've been using it for ten years and and
I know the rumors about crystal meth in
ten years is that it starts to you know
deteriorate your body you mean your body
start to decay your face your everything
I won't have any teeth in a couple years
or something like that if I keep using
it and I mean Carly right now I still
have my teeth five more years of that
yeah I can't continue using I know that
so I've been trying to quit
excellent well thank you so much for
talking to me and good luck out there
that's crazy
these things that hold on to people in
this neighborhood are so dangerous and
so discovered and you you see it it's
this dude put everything you got in to
be getting off the show yeah alright
thank you so much